now as for flights departing out of Reed
International our Candace elf Charles
joins us live this morning from the
airport to deliver the latest news of
what's going on there and also add some
holiday cheer for travelers and I hear
she might have a special friend with you
this morning what's going on Candace
good morning sir good morning folks yes
we've seen that there's about nearly 50
departure cancellations about 66 arrival
cancellations there are people sitting
on the floor here some people have been
coming by telling me their travel has
been difficult but we are here to spread
a little holiday cheer and I have
someone special here with me to join me
in the holiday chair Santa tell me a
little bit about how your travel has
been going Santa travel this morning has
been great and I'm just looking forward
to seeing everybody in Las Vegas today
at Reeder International Airport
well thankfully Santa's helped me spread
the holiday cheer because people have
been having such a hard time we have a
wonderful family that's coming from here
and they're going to be going to Atlanta
The Parkers thank you so much for
joining us how has your travel been so
far so far so good We snuck in right
when there was enough parking spots in
the parking garage so we got that
situated our flight's only 20 minutes
late so far so okay fingers crossed
fingers crossed fingers crossed good
luck you guys here's some candy canes
happy holidays
Finn and I will be here all morning
passing out candy canes some holiday
cheer we got you guys covered with all
the details of course about what's going
on here coming up we're going to be
speaking with airport staff about some
tips so you can make your travel a
little bit easier of course go to our
website for the latest on departures and
rival that's 8 News now.com for now live
from Harry International I'm Candace
Charles or Candice elf and Santa Aiden
is now